[Musique]
ah bonjour qu'est ce qui vous amène à ça
oui un couteau on est en 2018 je demande
pas une mitraillette je te demande pas
en bazooka mais je pourrais pas avoir un
pistolet plutôt qu'un couteau de merde
ça me prend une nuit pour tuer cinq ados
j'ai autre chose à [ __ ]
je vous connais vous c'est vous qui
sortez des tv tout ça manon justement je
sors plus des télé puisque tout le monde
a un iphone aujourd'hui
ah oui en effet alors à la limite une
tablette pourquoi pas je veux pas sain
pied je passe l'autre mais je passe pas
l'épaule et donc je fais comment moi
pour travailler vous dépensez ou herbe
les apple tv
comcast sur la millenium ça cartonne -
côté je comprends pas ce que vous dites
une fois j'ai fait ça pendant 10 minutes
confrères il était pas mort le mec mais
c'est très bien couteau au moins en
place originale qu'a déjà fait ça
pendant 10 minutes
est ce que vous faites là vous n'avez
pas de plein en fait c'est parce que à
chaque fois qu'on est sur le point de
faire l'amour on se fait tuer c'est un
peu contraignant pour nous quoi oui bon
ça je peux comprendre la limite rico
c'est chiant quoi mais bon ben moi je
suis pas méchante du tout je suis
fabricant de poupées et je sais pas
pourquoi les affaires marchent pas très
bien en ce moment
s'étonnant ça pendant tout le monde
aimait regrouper bah oui alors semble à
quoi alors j'ai un premier modèle que je
peux vous montrer ta [ __ ] elle fait
peur il va vous le tuez moi je vous
écoute et vous voyez le moment où ils
entendent un bruit flippant et ils ont
peur et en fait il se rend compte que
voilà c'est juste un chat oui je suis
pas juste un chat ok je m'appelle
pierrick j'aime la rando j'aime le
scrapbooking et justin cherche trouve ça
un peu réducteur voilà ce qu'on peut
faire
bon j'ai un autre modèle alors celui ci
j'ai préparé spécialement et je les fais
sur le modèle de mon épouse
d'accord voilà alors mon épouse ma
[ __ ]
non c'est pas mon style c'est bien mais
c'est pas mon style
j'ai vu je les ai vu ça et c'est bon
pour la la mais c'est pourquoi aux arts
et à regarder de ma [ __ ]
bonjour bonjour je tue des gens d'accord
jusqu'ici rien d'anormal
une cagoule c'est ce en fait le problème
c'est que je j'ai une cagoule parce que
tout le monde à les masquer coule donc
il me reste plus grand chose
est ce que je peux vous montrer j'en ai
quelques-uns mais non j'ai ça pas mal ça
ça ya l'idée mais non ça à cela il fait
un peu peur c'est celle à moi j'opterais
pour celui-là attendait cru que c'était
le vrai hockey bas salaires
allez merci oui je peux que apparaître
comme ça c'est ça le problème
eh ben je c'est justement ça ne va pas
être évidente non mais là par exemple
j'ai refusé mais là c'est juste le
bureau des plaintes pokémon cependant à
non non je suis pas un pokémon je suis
un monstre de série b je faisais très
peur dans les années 70 ça s'est pas
fait attendre et même si je fais
viendra-t-on ça tu vois ton pirates ans
et mon nom de monstres alors dites moi
alors mon problème c'est le nom que je
porte c'est quoi alors mon prénom c'est
ce à quoi ça alors ça arrive tout le
temps c'est chiant
mon prénom c'est ça je crois vous dit ça
mais vous montrez rien avec voudrais pas
si c'est parce que je peux pas indiquer
un truc parce que si je parle de mon
prénom mon prénom c'est ça mon prénom
égale ça elle raconte qu'un rap en
piratant mon prénom c'est ça c'était de
ma gueule c'est ça c'est ça super
portelli toutefois là c'est pas ça bon
laisser tomber on n'y arrivera pas non
je déconne je veux marcher
bon vous voulez quoi comme prénom lionel
j'aime bien
et encore vous alors le masque c'est
très bien mais par contre je cale sur
larmes je repars j'en ai quelques unes
dans le sac est ce que je peux vous
montrer ça ce truc là à sa guitare et sa
super ça hein ça ouais c'est lors on
peut savoir ouais voilà ça c'est bien
lourd et c'est parfait ça ok donc ça et
ça parfait ok go tellement attachant
j'espère qu'il va tuer plein de gens
[Musique]
je crois qu'ils agissent
et
[Musique]